2021 been a year of shortages as global
supply chains work to keep up with
demand crews try to manage around the
clock loading and unloading at our
nation's ports some of the top things
that were in short supply at one time
this year toilet paper hand sanitizer
and cleaning wipes some of the more
obscure items include ketchup packets
gaming consoles and oat milk
but as we all know the shortages don't
stop there especially with food items
and it is a new issue that's causing
concerns at one local bagel shop
christian costa rice joining us live in
studio with the shortage christian of
cream cheese and how it's impacting
restaurants and perhaps your bacon and
breakfast plans that's right brian cream
cheese may not be essential for most of
us but just as the owner of the bagel
cafe he fears this could really impact
his daily operations
if we stop getting it you know what do
you do i hope customers understand it's
not us cream cheese is a key ingredient
for this las vegas bagel shop but now
it's on the shortage list and customers
are shaking their head we love the cream
cheese especially they always have a
different flavor for us to try
and obviously with the shortage they
haven't been able to do that bagel cafe
owner savas andrews tells me it all
started a few weeks ago when he heard
other businesses complain about the
issue first i saw it on the news in new
york city the delis they have no cream
cheese to
serve their customers
so i started getting very concerned he
says his supplier alerted him about the
problem a crucial ingredient for his
most popular menu item but also used for
baking and his popular cheesecakes i
will be able to last me about a week and
a half schreiber foods is a product
supplier of cream cheese a spokesperson
for the company says the shortage stems
from the pandemic labor shortages and of
course now the worldwide supply chain
disruptions schreiber foods believes
it's a short-term issue and claims
everyone is trying to keep up with
demand until then this bagel shop hopes
its customers understand they have lots
of other good stuff here so
i mean i don't think i wouldn't come
just because they didn't have creek keys
well the bagel cafe owner tells me he
hopes this problem is resolved sooner
than later in fact to help combat the
shortage kraft foods you know the maker
of philadelphia cream cheese well
they're offering a 20 digital reward i
put all that information all those
details on our website it's available
right now 8newsnow.com
christian casa is live local now